this was a brief stop in the UK for the
U.S president on route to meteor
discussions at the NATO Summit in
Lithuania
and our familiar handshake at the front
door this is the fifth time Rishi sunak
and Joe Biden have met in as many months
[Applause]
the president's time in Downing Street
limited to just 40 minutes and in public
to expressions of solidarity and
cooperation we head from here to Nato
and Vilnius where we stand as two of the
firmest allies in that Alliance and I
know we'll want to do everything we can
to strengthen euro-atlantic security but
great pleasure to have you here it's
good to be back you know we've only been
meeting once a month
met in San Diego Belfast Hiroshima
Washington here and uh couldn't be
meeting with a closer friend and a
greater Ally
these are allies though with important
differences over policy Downing Street
said that prime minister sunak had
upheld the UK's obligations under its
membership of the convention on cluster
Munitions to discourage their use
President Biden has committed descending
cluster bombs to Ukraine differences too
over Ukraine's eventual NATO membership
the United States known to be
considerably more reluctant about the
time scale than Britain
[Music]
on climate policy at least where the
president has upset some Western allies
with nearly 400 billion dollars of
planned subsidies for Green Tech
development in the U.S he was likely to
find some common ground with Britain's
new King in his new role Charles III is
more constrained in his campaigning than
he was when Prince of Wales but the
environment remains his most dearly held
cause
hence his hosting of this forum designed
to encourage more private sector
investment in climate change mitigation
the nearer-term issues of the Ukraine
war and the makeup of NATO are at the
center though of Biden's European trip
to be tackled in Vilnius on Tuesday
Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera London